we were up at curiae which is at the
farthest island out in the chain and we
were down at 300 feet in an area where
we've documented every single fish on
this reef is a species known only from
the Hawaiian Islands it's the truly the
most unique set of fission on earth and
out of the corner of my eye I saw a
flash it was a little pink fish and
there are lots of little pink fish down
there so that didn't get my attention
what got my attention was on the dorsal
fin of this fish there's a spot a big
red spot with a blue ring around it on
the dorsal fin and I thought no fish I
know of has this color and very quickly
we determined it was a brand new species
and the most distinctive feature about
this fish was that spot on its dorsal
fin big red spot with a blue ring around
which minded me of a certain logo of a
presidential candidate hope it's a hopes
but that's exactly right this fish is
special because it's the only fish we
know of that lives only in the monument
so I monumental fits a monumental fish
it's a monumental discovery we have
decided that we're going to name this
fish in honor of President Obama toast
anoikis Obama that's exactly right I
have a favor to ask Sylvia tomorrow
you're gonna be meeting the President of
the United States here at Midway at all
and ask for his essentially permission
for us to name it in his honor I'm sure
he'll accept but I just before we do
that I want to make sure he's a he's a
willing participant in this will be my
honor to be an ambassador for you and
for tus annoyed ease
[Music]
wait what's up
[Music]